[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na arena o
podcast semanal onde a gente indica
troca idei sobre conteúdos que a gente
leu ouviu assistiu sempre trazendo visão
de produto PR discussão eu sou o Artur
tem feriadin aí eu sou a E você já se
ligou que é o último feriado dia de
semana do ano Caral Moque era tava eliz
e agora
você eu tô eu tô Bad energies né Car Tá
mesmo não você tem que ver eu mandei 300
coisas pro a ele respondeu só acabando
com meus sonhos em todos [__] essa
pauta aqui mandei um link para ele [__]
vamos falar sobre isso a ele tá blá blá
blá pum sim não não tem pau falei caraca
mano tá difíc o pior é que hoje eu nem
tô nem tô energia baixa nem tô volado
nem nada só imagina você at tenho que
aturar é
verdade mas no programa de hoje a gente
vai falar dos seguintes
assuntos O que fazer quando falta tempo
para consumir as coisas conteúdos e
afins e um giro de notícias do mundo de
ai e sabe aqui o que eu tava pensando
antes de ir para o jabazinho mico é que
cara esse programa é muito especial e
você é um cara à frente do tempo porque
seus pais colocaram o seu nome de AX
então é o único programa que tem alguém
com com ai no nome que fala sobre ai é
verdade eu achei que você ia falar que é
parecido com x ou que é
x invertido não é mas também poderia ser
então fica aí foi menos criativo do que
eu imaginei que você seria tá vendo é
vai lá vamos falar o nosso jabazinho da
semana vamos lá né então assim você já
sabe né que tem curso vindo aí final de
Junho vai ter o curso online de
pensamento crítico e analítico com o
Dudu e comigo vocês a gente já falou
aqui no último episódio da Galera
elogiando do curso falou Caraca nem
sabia que eu precisava de fazer esse
curso até fazer ele isso é tão bom que
ftou um episódio inteiro né
exato e é assim se você ainda tá com
dúvida assiste lá o episódio anterior
que a gente falou mais um montão sobre
Mas então dia 29/06 vai ser a edição
mais uma edição online ao vivo e no dia
6/07 presencial aqui em São Paulo lá na
casa da prtica arena na juus E além
disso no dia 20 de julho também é um
sábado tem mais uma edição do curso de
ai para
PMs comigo e com efren e o nosso
a vai tá lá também falando contando do
GPT que ele criou agora tudo faz sentido
você consegue fazer os gpts e tudo mais
porque você fala a língua não só fala a
língua como o nome seu nome já você é o
prometido da
ai como é que é o do duna você viu duna
e o l não já dormi 10 vezes tentando
assistir mas sempre duam é da hora o d
não é da hora não é da hora é mas enfim
o link com desconto tá na descrição
e a gente se vê lá não deixa PR comprar
na última hora aí você vai comprar vai
comprar o último lote que vai est mais
caro sendo que a gente já tá avisando
com antecedência aqui né aproveita para
pagar mais barato agora e com o desconto
do podcast a na descrição é isso agora
sim bora lá PR paa Bora lá
[Música]
bom nas últimas semanas elas foram meio
puxadas aqui na na papo na arena
Corporation e podcast né É acho que
tanto eu quanto você a gente teve mais
agarrado aí com trabalho e
consequentemente isso impacta aqui no
nosso ritmo de consumo de conteúdo e de
coisas que a gente TR pro Podcast né E
aí eu fiquei pensando pô por que não
fazer desse limão uma limonada né e
fazer isso aqui virar o conteúdo porque
é bem comum no nosso dia a dia em
produto a gente se sentir sobrecarregado
com trabalho com todas as demandas
reuniões que a gente tem normalmente e
às vezes sem a gente perceber mesmo a
gente acaba deixando de lado ou até
mesmo não querendo fazer esse consumo de
coisas fora do horário por sentir que é
trabalho mas é o tipo de coisa que se
você deixar escapa e quando você vê você
não tá fazendo né E aí queria começar
esse assunto sabendo de você meu querido
co-host que que você faz ou o que que
você prioriza para consumir nesses
momentos Onde você tá mais corrido e
[__] no dia a dia uma ótima pergunta
mas uma das coisas que eu acho que a
primeira coisa né já que você fala Tem
tempo que eu não falo essa célebre frase
eu vou falar aqui né que é trabalhe
trabalhe trabalhe mas não significa não
se esqueça que as vírgulas significam
pausas já ter tentado adivinhar antes
você ia falar ela só para eu mostrar
como eu te conheço é pois é hoje você tá
me super estimando hein subestimando
hoje aí ó
eh mas vamos lá cara Acho que a primeira
coisa assim a gente a gente [__] já falou
isso algumas vezes a gente já recebeu
esse feedback também tipo dá de a gente
você máquinas de consumir conteúdo né
que tipo a gente consome muito conteúdo
não sei o quanto ser é bom ou ruim mas
assim é uma realidade isso é com
contrafatos não argumentos né exato
exatamente só que tem tem um lado bom
disso de né você tá antenado sabendo o
que que tá rolando e quando a gente fala
sobre do tipo consumir conteúdo não é só
conteúdo de produto né é conteúdos dos
mais derivados possíveis assim que podem
podem ou não ter correlação com produtos
mas cara uma das coisas que eu
respondendo a pergunta né Uma das coisas
que eu faço bastante assim para quando o
ritmo Tá muito corrido é o que que eu
não abro mão do tipo eu não abro mão de
fazer meus exercícios quer dizer de vez
quando até abro né mas assim tento
manter a sanidade fazendo exercício
então e uma parada que eu desenvolvi
graças a você inclusive antig
eu não conseguia coisa boa pra sua vida
velho é mais ou menos né e Antigamente
eu não conseguia por exemplo correr
escutando escutando podcast hoje em dia
eu mal consigo correr escutando música
tá ligado Então essa é uma coisa que que
virou muito a minha chave então eu acabo
usando esses momentos por exemplo pô
essas últimas semanas tô muito corrido
mas cara eu continuo escutando meus
podcasts pô Tô usando mais do que nunca
o SPE que eu já falei que vários
episódios sobre ele assim de conteúdos
que fazem mais sentido que eu pô que eu
quero ler não quero deixar muito para
depois então é isso assim então pô eu
escuto bastante dois podcasts assim pô
muito quer dizer três diariamente um é o
o denils pô que é cara 15 minutinhos tem
o morning brill Daily também que é pô as
notícias gringa e tal escuto tem o do
Tech crunch e o Stretch Cherry cara são
os quatro assim que eu cons conso que
são menores e que eu consumo sempre
assim diariamente mesmo e é isso eu
acordo tomando café já já escuto ou
quando tô fazendo meu exercício aqui já
escuto correndo e tal então acho que
essa é uma coisa e outra é aquele olhada
passada de olho no e-mail mesmo de das
News leers tá ligado que você acompanha
de dar uma olhada salvar o que faz
sentido no pocket para depois ler com
calma mas é as coisas que eu costumo a
fazer assim para não não não ficar
totalmente alheio alheio é mas e mas de
novo assim é o lance de depende dos
momentos tem momentos que é cara sem
consumir mesmo e é isso aí férias
principalmente é até desinstala e-mails
e etc tipo assim Slack então desinstala
e fala assim Vou ficar off mesmo quero
ficar devani pelo mundo alheio cara é
curiosa essa parada
do ligar né e e do que você falou no
início de [__] a gente precisa ser
produtivo sempre o quanto isso é ser
porque eu sinto às vezes isso Tipo pô às
vezes eu tenho domingo de manhã é um
horário que eu gosto de ler né de coisas
que eu salvei ali durante a semana para
depois ou newsletters mais longas e aí
às vezes [__] ten um compromisso domingo
de manhã ou alguma coisa assim não
consigo fazer aí eu fico [__] pensando
depois né pô não li e tal deixei de
consumir aquela parada Então tem um
pouco disso mas aí eu acho que entra
outra parada que para mim tem um pouco
do gosto de consumir essas coisas que eu
não sinto que é trabalho e eu sinto que
eu já conversei com várias pessoas que
tem isso ah mas trabalho é conteúdo de
trabalho não sei qu e eu legitimamente e
não tô falando que as pessoas têm que
ser igual a mim não eu tô falando só
como eu me sinto tá eu curto acompanhar
essas coisas de Tecnologia de negócios
como um todo então você falou ah nas
férias às vezes dou desligada
eu pelo contrário o tempo que eu tenho
livre é tipo férias coisas assim cara é
a hora que eu vou mergulhar nas paradas
vou ler as coisas com mais profundidade
eu vou continuar acompanhando o dia a
dia porque eu curto mesmo eu acho que é
natural aqui meu mas de novo né Não acho
todo mundo tem que ser assim mas acho
que ajuda quando é uma parada que você
curte
é nossa é aquela frase clichê mas
Trabalhe com que você gosta
quem diria que eu ia tá falando quem
diria que
o link Disney a frase link Disney da
semana vai vamos lá pausa PR a frase
link Disney da semana Trabalhe com o que
você gosta e consuma o conteúdo não vai
ser consumir o conteúdo sobre isso não
vai ser
trabalho Nossa
Senhora tomar minha carteirinha de de
anticapitalismo daqui a
pouco mas fora isso né Eu acho que eu
tenho uma rotina bem parecida com você
velho nesse sentido assim que mesmo
nessas semanas que eu tô [__] tem as
paradas que eu não abro mão e que Eu
encaixo então tem algumas poucas
newsletters diárias que eu vou abrir eu
vou achar um espaço na minha agenda e
normalmente é o horário de manhã eu
reservo ali é meia hora 40 minutos PR
para L mail isso vai paraos e-mails de
newsletters também que é acho tem até
interseção que você falou o morning brew
você ouve o podcast eu consuma
newsletter para mim funciona melhor
consumir a newsletter mais Car mas isso
mas isso inclusive é até
um uma mudança de de comportamento assim
mudança de mídia que você consome o
conteúdo de uma específica marca né hoou
de algum específico blog etc Eu também
consumia tanto theils quanto do Morning
brill eu consumia a newsletter ferrenha
assim era as primeiras que eu olhava
Quando eu acordava assim e tals agora os
dois tipo é o contrário eu mal leio a
newsletter é só o podcast só escuto o
podcast dos dois chave é é isso
é tem algum que eu que eu vi assim como
o stret Cherry stret Cherry também a
mesma coisa STR Cherry É [__] porque S
os textos são densos né são textos
longos mais densos assim é E aí eu podc
cara porque Pô dá para consumir bem de
boa assim sabe é e e de diário além do
Morning brew tem duas brasileiras que eu
sempre leio também que a são mais de
negócio em geral que é o new feed e o
Brasil Journal é Brasil Journal também é
bem bom é eu eu soli Apesar de eu de eu
ter discordâncias ideológicas com o
conteúdo do Brasil Journal muito às
vezes eu acho que são bons conteúdos de
negócio serve para me dar uma visão
geral e E desde que começou o Boom ji Eu
também tenho uma News algumas
newsletters que eu sigo que são diárias
mas é que eu sinto que todo dia eu abro
Pelo menos é a Ben bites e eu acho que
inclusive mudou de nome para de neuron
alguma coisa assim mas é a minha go
newsletter para saber as novidades do
dia e produtos novos e aí eu tenho Fala
aí fala aí não eu ia falar de uma outra
coisa que eu faço que a gente já até
falou em episódios anteriores assim às
vezes quando tá muito corrido eu tenho o
meu perfil só de No Instagram só de de
coisas Tech que eu sigo ajuda né ajuda
que aí eu dou uma olhada assim seja logo
de manhã hoou de tarde aquela hora que
você acorda quer dar aquela olhar
escolada né eu vou lá e uso uso ess Fed
do Twitter o algoritmo é tão louco que
não dá para você saber se vai vir as
coisas que você quer saber assim em
geral o Twitter já foi muito minu meu go
to Place para esse tipo de coisa mas
hoje em dia o o que eu faço o que eu
faço com o twitter também é eu tenho
minha lista lá de cara eu sempre faço
isso a pessoa que eu começo a seguir etc
que eu vejo que tem conteúdo maneiro eu
adiciono nessa lista então às vezes
também eu acordo cara é a rotina é essa
assim eu vou orar e você tá corrido né
pô Vou lá Olha as minhas eu dou uma
olhada nas principais notícias ali dou
uma olhada na minha lista lá das pessoas
que eu sigo no no twitter também né que
aí já vai só os tweets delas mesmo e bom
isso já dá uma Você tá é o giro de
notícias que Inclusive a gente vai fazer
já já també mas além das diárias aí tem
umas que eu olho mas tipo não consegui
ler no dia mas que eu vou ler no fim da
semana com certeza quando tiver um tempo
então tipo strater é isso para mim [__]
eu sei que eu vou ter que dedicar um
tempo ali para ler que às vezes eu não
vou conseguir durante semana no final de
semana eu vou ler a newsletter do
benedict Evans é a mesma coisa então só
algumas que eu tenho assim que ah não
consegui no dia a dia mas eu vou
reservar um tempo e se falou de Podcast
né também para para mim é o é o negócio
que salva muito porque mesma coisa que
você assim eu tento não abrir mão da
rotina de exercícios e para mim Eu falo
isso para todo mundo eu vou pra academia
para ouvir podcast velho é para não não
atrasar a minha lista ali de de Podcast
E aí quando as coisas estão um pouco
mais Ferradas que eu sinto tá acumulando
muito eu dou uma acelerada para ouvir no
1.5 ou no dois dependendo ali do do
podcast e e encaixando ele na rotina nas
pequenas coisas assim também então p vou
lavar louça aí pô 15 minutinhos al
lavando louça vou ouvir alguma coisa vou
parar para lanchar aqui aí eu boto ali
para ouvir é então eu também encaixo
isso e tem uma parada que você me
ensinou quando a gente trabalhou junto
anos atrás tá vendo só trago coisas boas
pra sua vida cara primeira coisa que eu
sinto aqui que foi boa que
sacanagem não mas que não sei se você
faz isso até hoje mas você tinha o Você
trabalhava com Pomodoro se eu não me
engano aí no seu no seu espaço de break
do pomodoro você abria lá o Pocket ia
ler alguma coisa EA aí ele ficava
mandando no nos canais da empresa né os
artigos e tal e aí eu tento fazer isso
também às vezes no nos espacinhos na
agenda cara vez tem 15 minutos entre uma
reunião e outra não tem tipo um chat ali
para responder nada do tipo eu abro o
poet eu abro meu meu coisa de
newsletters ali vou ler alguma coisa
rapidinho então dou essas encaixadas ao
longo do dia quando dá que tipo às vezes
é melhor do que ficar rolando o feed do
Twitter ou o
tiktok acho que é isso são as coisas que
eu faço aí bem parecidas os nossos
inclusive é isso
inclusive se você faz alguma coisa
diferente manda para nós aí é isso se
tiver recomendações aí também de Pô eu
leio essa newsletter todo dia US esses
podcast diário aqui então manda pra
gente também pra gente conhecer ouvir
experimentar
[Música]
bom e no bloco dois se você tá corrido
aí como a gente esteve nas últimas
semanas a gente vai passar um giro de
notícias do que rolou semana passada e
esse início de semana a gente tá
gravando na segunda-feira apesar do
podcast ir pro ar na quarta véspera de
feriado mas vamos trazer um giro das
notícias aí do que que tá rolando no
mundo de ai né Ah bom a notícia mais
recente é que a x vai levantar o a ao
contrário
vai vai levantar 6 bilhões é isso é 6
bilhões é o tamanho da rodada não é o
valuation exato com o PR 18
B só isso cara eu não consigo é uma
coisa fora de qualquer valor para mim
assim ou seja só saque tá o X que é o
chat PT do Elon musk né para para
simplificar que tem lá o grock né que é
a o nome da ai deles tá fazendo uma
rodada levantando seis
bilhões dos principais fundos de
investimento e e PR referência né a Open
a estimativa que o valuation dela é em
80 B E aí falando 80 B uma empresa que
tem centenas de milhares de usuários tem
um produto que gera receita tipo
obviamente eles operam no prejuízo ainda
mas tem um produto aí que tá na boca do
povo né E e aí você pensa assim [__] o
xai realmente vale essa porcentagem da
da Open ai tipo o que que tem aí tá os
caras valerem 20 25% de uma Open ai sabe
Pois é qual que é a tese Será que tá por
trás disso aí né desse para justificar
esse tamanho desse investimento porque
em termos de testes e etc mesmo que eles
lançaram várias coisas aí desde Novembro
até então mas por exemplo os aquelas
avaliações de Alucinação lá o grock até
alucion mais do que as demais né do que
os demais os demais players de ai aí
então assim o que que tá por trás disso
é o ecossistema da ex e do El musk de
todo do mundo porque para quem não sabe
Hello musk é um dos fundadores também da
do Open ai né é um dos investidores
iniciais al da ideia exato e Cara eu não
sei tipo eu não vejo ninguém sério
usando grock ou ou falando disso tipo
como um competidor de de fato ali dos
grandes modelos eh de llm e eu fico até
pensando ah sei lá o grock pode ser
treinado ali no os dados do Twitter né e
e o Twitter eventualmente não licenciar
isso para ninguém Isso é exclusividade
mas não sei se tá acompanhando o o
Google começou a liberar os ai previews
no nos Estados Unidos e pro mundo todo e
a galera tá trazendo alguns Absurdos
principalmente coisas que são
correlacionadas com respostas dadas no
Reddit né
E se no Reddit o negócio a respostas
treinadas com o post do redit já tá
desse jeito gerando essas coisas imagina
no Twitter que é o [__] não me orgulho
disso mas é o LXR do mundo digital ali
né eu tô Ali há 1 anos mas é isso velho
é uma maluquice
então sei lá
velho não sei o que pensar consigo
pensar que dinheiro dinheiro tá sempre
aí né Para quem para quem consegue
convencer bem as pessoas pois é mais que
a gente tem aí de de Notícias não tem
mais nada para falar do grock não do
grock É aí vamos ver o que que vai vai
vir por aí bom falando um pouquinho da
Open Ai também né semana passada
aconteceu um monte de coisa e saiu mais
gente lá do time de Safety deles lá eles
inclusive acabaram lá com com um dos
times né e tals então é inclusive eu
achei esse o negócio meio over assim a
reação das pessoas porque tipo saiu o
líder de de Safety e tal e era um time
um time dedicado a isso só que pelas
notícias obviamente né O que sai na
imprensa a a empresa controla ali mas
parece muito mais uma reestruturação de
não é que acabou o time de Safe é que
agora eles acoplar as pessoas de saf ou
ou as demandas de Safety em outros times
né obviamente Pode não ter o mesmo peso
eh os mesmos recursos eles dedicavam 20%
do poderio de processamento deles para
esse time velho é muita coisa se você
pensar que a galera tá brigando por GPU
no mundo né
então ainda assim tipo sei lá não não
achei tão bizarro quanto muitas pessoas
fizeram parecer na internet é E aí mais
duas coisas é que finalmente
oficializaram a parceria com o redit né
Open ai então ou seja vaii treinar os
modelos no redit lá além disso a Open ai
vai virar um parceiro de ads da do
Reddit e tem rolando uma confusãozinha
aí porque a Open a ela não consegue
ficar ass uma confusão né não tem como
emesa
empresa
é porque o o Sama ele é ele tem uma
porcentagem do redit né ele tem um monte
era do porque ele era do IC Então já
estão falando de conflito de interesse
[__] mas assim o Sama Ele tá em todas
ele não tem
é bizarro Eu já vi as empresas que ele
tem participação tipo é o Vale do
solicit tá ligado então o cara
literalmente ele é o conflito de
interesse humano não tem muito o que
fazer nesse sentido é E aí acho que a
última coisa também que terminou ficou
disponível na semana passada o app do
chat GPT agora tá disponível pro Mac
também
e e tô usando tô gostando importante né
É só para Max com chip Apple Silicon né
e e Inclusive eu fui pesquisar o por quê
Porque o meu Mac aqui do trabalho não é
Apple Silicon é um Intel ainda E aí eles
falaram não lembro se foi no chat no
fórum da Open ai ou no Reddit alguém da
empresa falou que é porque eles vão usar
recursos exclusivos ali que só tem
disponível nos chips da Apple Muito
provavelmente o os processadores neurais
né os npu que tem ali então pode ter a
ver com
isso não vão ter uma versão para para
Max Intel a no futuro e aí Acho que mais
uma treta que rolou foi da da escada R
eu ia falar isso teve isso né então
começou com o pessoal vindo dizer olha
gente rolou uma confusão e vocês estavam
achando que a nossa demo aqui os
negócios de voz já iam estar disponíveis
assim que acabasse Não vai est ainda a
gente vai rolar outar aos poucos então
tiveram que no Twitter falar isso E aí
uma duas semanas depois lá olou A
Scarlet johanson aparentemente
processando ali a openi né aparentemente
ela teve conversas com samman que o Sam
altman queria usar a voz dela no ali pra
demo e pro chat GPT né para todos os
recursos de voz e ela não cedeu a voz
dela não quis e curiosamente a voz usada
parece muito com a da Scarlet
johanson copia mas não faz igual né já
dizia alguém exato né
falou nada se cria tudo se transforma já
dizia ai [__] Então teve isso vamos
ver qual da pra próxima semana quais
serão aí os tá bom os novos embroli da
Open ai e acho que para fechar né a
gente também teve o evento da Microsoft
na semana passada que a gente acabou não
comentando o Microsoft build foi muito
focado em ai apesar de ser um evento de
de hardware de lançamento de hardware
lançaram os novos notebook Surface ali
eles falaram muito muito muito muito ji
Então acho que principais coisas os
CoPilot mais PCs que são PCs Windows que
tem specs e focadas ali em ter
funcionalidade dei de ter o CoPilot
integrado então eu achei bem legal isso
porque dá uma balizada nos modelos né
acho que uma coisa que fala tanto de
Windows quanto de Android né É que por
ser um sistema licenciado você tem
diversos specs diferentes e é difícil
desenvolver ali então os os PCs que vão
ter o selo CoPilot mais eles precisam
ter pelo menos 250 GB de SSD 16 GB de
Ram e 40 teraflops de npu que são as
unidades de processamento de
Inteligência Artificial ali que para
comparação os Macbook airs mais recentes
com os pm3 tem 18 né então é esperado
uma capacidade de processamento maior
Inclusive eu fiquei pensando e aí com já
conectando aqui com o segundo ponto né
que eles apresentaram o CoPilot
integrado ao Windows né então ele vendo
tudo que você faz com a possibilidade de
lembrar a sones que você fez né
inclusive rolou um burburinho
relacionado à privacidade sobre isso e é
totalmente parecido com o que a Open ai
mostrou no app de Mac deles assim é um
app que tá ali o tempo todo com você e
que você pode interagir então fiquei
pensando o quanto não ter um app do chat
ept para Windows não é meio que uma
cláusula de não compete de certa forma
assim então tipo a gente tem um tempo
para ter o o CoPilot rodando e depois
vocês lançam o App para windows para
evitar uma canibalização sabe é ou se
não é um White Label né do tipo alguma
coisa assim motor por trás é a mesma
coisa na teoria né são os modelos da
open
muda interface mas o mot coisa a gente
vai usar a mesma coisa só que aqui vai
ser a carinha bonitinha da integrada já
aqui do CoPilot lá e deixa deixa fazer
um aplicativo lá que eles gostam de app
né a Apple gosta então fazo para ele ex
é mas acho que assim como o evento do
Google né a Microsoft tem dezenas de
apps serviços onde eles podem adicionar
o CoPilot ali e ai eles fizeram várias
demos do durante o build sobre isso
então e eu tô tô ansioso para usar aí e
mais funcionalidade do CoPilot integrado
ao so eu acho que tem um potencial a
gente que passa o dia inteiro no
computador trabalhando no computador de
Fato né e tem um negócio ali aberto que
se não monerar muito o computador pode
servir como um assistente real eu acho
que vai ser muito [__] não sei como é
que tá sendo a sua experiência usando aí
o chat GPT no Mac se se você tá Cara eu
tô tá sendo útil Mas tem uma parada me
incomodando porque eles TM um um atalho
lá para você inicializar o para fazer as
perguntas sabe que E aí pausa o
onboarding é muito bom do do app na hora
que você instala cara é muito legal na
hora que você instala a primeira coisa
que ele mostra lá o o coisa aqui para
você ativar o eles até dão um nome que é
o atalho do inicializador Uhum E aí de
esp ass o que que o chat GPT pode fazer
E aí na hora que você dá já aparece na
tela para você dar o enter e então assim
é muito legal a experiência e Cara eu tô
usando bastante o screenshots tem
funcionado e tal assim então tá sendo
como eu já usava bastante para mim tá
sendo mais prático porque agora tá Putz
já tá na minha eu não preciso abrir o
navegador para não precisa ficar
trocando de aba né Eu acho saco também
velho isso tá sendo é isso tá reduzindo
Pass e melhorando minha minha
experiência então é isso eu fico
pensando se tipo é para ter um um uso
meio assistente mesmo sabe você tá
olhando para eu eu comentei na semana
passada né que eles fizeram melhorias na
parte de análise de dados e essa semana
eu dei uma testada melhor assim eu fiz
uma análise junto com eles assim eu fico
imaginando o quão mais fluido isso pode
ser tipo você olhando uma tabela e
conversando de fato com o chat GPT
enquanto ele faz Faz aquela análise sabe
ele vai mostrando o gráfico em vez de
você ir digitando o que você quer você
falar [__] agora dá um drill Down nisso
[__] me mostra isso agora ao longo do
tempo pá categoriza desse jeito agora
é tipo é você de fato T um assistente
fazendo as coisas para você ali né e eu
acho que vai muito na linha do que acho
que a gente já indicou esse texto aqui
do do ay falando sobre cada vez mais a a
a gente vai passar de noled workers né
de trabalhador hoje do conhecimento ali
PR a location workers que a gente vai
ter que aprender a locar melhor os ai
Agents em cada uma das ações e quem faz
o qu Então acho que é um passo em
direção a isso sabe Então tá vamos ver
que mais que a gente tem né semana que
vem e é isso aí toda semana uma grande
grandes
novidades é
[Música]
isso e vamos pro nosso blo de produtos
essa semana vamos lá semana passada eu
comecei Então vai aí tá o 10 o meu é o
Meg cara o aplicativo do banco L que
inclusive semana passada a gente falou
mas cara eu realmente assim o meu caso
de uso para ele tá sendo meu segundo
banco mesmo assim só que e é única e
exclusivamente pelo conta da facilidade
de menos cliques também que eu preciso
dar de por exemplo Ps eu joguei mandei
uma grana lá PR para lá para quando eu
precisar fazer esses pics tipo esse
final de semana tava em Santa R testar
né testar e também para testar lógico
mas eu tava lá em Santa Rita do Passa qu
uma cidade que né da cidade do Mozão e
lá as Tava tendo kermess E aí para eu
comprar os oeg na época de festa jina né
as fichas do bingo eu tinha que pagar
não tinha dinheiro né físico eu tinha
que pagar no pix mas se eu tivesse que
abrir aí é olha quantos quantas
interações são você tem que abrir
desbloquear seu celular Abrir o
aplicativo do banco colocar a a senha f
na Home Screen provavelmente então
colocar a senha entrar no negocinho lá
no item do pix digitar o pix ou clicar
para ler o qrcode aí confirmar colocar
sua senha de novo e aí e ainda Mostrar a
tela então só isso aí se já foi um temp
aí cara é uma maravilha você vai lá tira
o Tira a foto já no WhatsApp direto pum
faz o Pix de tanto para esse lugar aqui
ele ainda não fez uma otimização Mas
acabou de começar né então a gente dá um
desconto mas assim não tá muito
otimizado lá a leitura da das imagens
demora um pouquinho mas é muito mais
rápido do que todos os outros cliques
que Eu precisaria dar mas tá funcionando
muito bem é muito prático e Enfim nem é
pu mas
quero ver lembrou que eu fui liberado
aqui aí tinha que mandar o documento
para continuar o fluxo e eu não
continuei eu preciso voltar lá tá vendo
sacanagem viu mas uma coisa que eu
fiquei tava conversando inclusive com a
pilon e com o Lucas é vantagem
competitiva porque assim no final das
contas são bem rasamente falando assim
mas são um monte de apis né que do tipo
os bancos já T todos isso só não tem a
interface do WhatsApp mesmo né quanto
tempo até os apps os bancos se isso
realmente for uma coisa se isso vai do
esse movimento os bancos fazerem isso
também E aí o quanto seria diferencial
aí mas enfim tô usando recomendo e você
cara o meu eu vou falar aqui do Duolingo
não lembro se eu já trouxe o Duolingo
mas eu certamente já falei que para
caramba mas vou trazer por um motivo
especial porque hoje eu estou
completando 1000 dias de ofensiva no
Duolingo [__] chegando num num Marco
aqui do uso do app Eu já eu já falei sim
porque a gente comentou aqui sobre
mandou mandou a pelúcia do do Du PR mim
aí eu tô chegando nos 1 dias e tá dia
desse Tava tendo uma discussão no
twitter também sobre [__] Quanto é
efetivo aprender língua no duol lingo
quanto não é só um negócio de
entretenimento e tal e cara se é
entretenimento Pelo menos é o
entretenimento que eu tô aprendendo uns
negócios
aprendendo um francesinho leve ali dia
desse eu tive tive que ler um negócio em
francês no trabalho era um parágrafo
velho eu consegui ler ele inteiro assim
eu falei [__] legal velho um tempo
atrás eu não teria mínima ideia do que
tá escrito aqui então mesmo que seja
brincando eu sinto que eu tô tô
aprendendo alguma coisa ali então é não
não deixem de usar o Duolingo porque
vocês acham Ah não é o método mais
efetivo de aprender porque alguma coisa
você vai aprender velho então anda ver é
isso que mais que a galera mandou aí pra
gente essa semana ó hoje meu time
inteiro mandou mandou coisas Espero que
você não tenha tido que co agilos
informação aí eu não
vou mas então quer mandar primeiro um
salve aqui pro time a miram mandou o
aplicativo do quinto andar a Karina
mandou o splitwise tinha tempo que não
aparecia o splitu né
é top cinco mais citados aqui certamente
total exato o kau novo integrante aí do
time mandou Mox stopper que é um app PR
do mic aí para sei lá fazer o que no no
mic no jogo de carta lá mesmo que jogo
Car S Eu tenho uns amigos que são nerd
do mic até hoje pois o neui que é o um
dos nossos devis lá da da Dock também
mandou o chat PT é falou que tá usando
um monte a que é a outra Tech Lead né o
Neu é um Tech a an é a outra te que Lady
lá mandou tecnofit Box que é o app dela
CrossFit lá e tal ela é toda do Cross
participou de um campeonato esses dias
aí um salve NAD ficou em sexto lugar aí
e o Lucas ele tá três semanas mandando
isso eu mas ele manda em 300 lugares
diferente e aí ele não é visto ele não é
lido e lembrado em nenhum aí na hora que
eu vou colocar aqui no centrar Alia
parada não consigo né mas ele mandou o
swift key que é o da o teclado da
Microsoft né ah do Microsoft Swift exato
e enfim os produtos mais antigos que eu
uso de porque eu acho que no meu
primeiro
Android um Nexus 4 em
2012 eu acho alguma coisa assim já usava
o Swift k depois a Microsoft comprou mas
na época ele era muito diferente acho
que todo teclado hoje em dia já tem isso
mas ele tinha as sugestões de de pal que
não era o negócio que tinha na época ele
tinha o negócio de você digitar
deslizando o dedo que não era negó
deslizando Nossa ess era mai legal n era
maior cool exatamente então foi um
negócio inovador Depois todo mundo
copiou hoje em dia eu não sei se tem
nada inovador mas eu pego o celular novo
é uma das primeiras coisas que eu
instalo é o swifty é isso continu
mandando os apps de
[Música]
vocês e com isso a gente encerra o
programa de hoje pois é né cara é isso
mais uma semana mais um programinha aí
no ar pra galera ouvir a véspera do
feriado no feriado depois do feriado e
espero que não só ouvir mas também
compartilhar né mandar aí pr paraum
amiguinho para amiguinha se você achar
que alguém pode curtir esse programa se
alguém que você sabe que tá ferrado não
tá conseguindo acompanhar as notícias de
ai fala assim ó a galera fez um resumo
aí das coisas que aconteceu Dá um ouvido
aí nesse bloco que a pessoa gosta né
e manda pra gente aí aonde você tá
escutando o podcast nessas últimas
semanas já teve gente mandando que tava
escutando enquanto tava andando de bike
neui falou que vai escutar fazendo
exercício da da academia aí o treino
dele e vocês manda aí marca a gente lá
posta lá ó pago treino pago podcast
check exato exato não e não importa onde
você ouça pode ser no Spotify no YouTube
no
substack qualquer lugar que você ouva
podcasts aí você ouva podcasts é [__] né
que você ouça
podcast
moleque a gente estará lá prontos para
receber a sua viida é isso então depois
do feriado semana que vem o Descanse o
feriado aí pá aproveitem e semana que
vem gente tá de volta e semana que vem
tem novidades fica aí fica aí o teaser
fica aí ó o teaser para saber se você
vai ouvir ou não na semana que vem mas
vai ter uma novidade para abalar as
estruturas abalar as estruturas mudar o
mundo do
podcast Exatamente é isso então valeu
valeu